this is incredible to be sitting here
with tauren yater wallace tauren
thanks for being here thank you when did
you start skiing uh
around like one and a half or one
somewhere in there one
is that really starting skiing or is
that just abandoning a child down
i can only assume you weren't potty
trained which means you were just
letting it loose whenever do you miss
that freedom sometimes when you're just
standing there at the top of the half
pipe and you just really wish you could
just let it go right there you know but
are you wearing a dry suit could you let
it go i mean i suppose you could but
i don't think it would be as comfortable
as it was when i was one and you're
upside down a lot so it would really
kind of get a good coat on you what's
the difference between skiing and
snowboarding when it comes to tricks
skiing tricks have different names that
sound kind of stupid or sometimes but
grabs on snowboards though like they got
some crazy names too like roast beef is
one of them that's a snowboard trick
beef curtains beef curtains go get on
your board and rip open some beef
curtains nose bone like with your nose
bone yep are you familiar with the
etymology of these tricks uh no do you
know the word etymology no
i hate skiing love a ski lodge it's like
i can't blame you though for loving the
ski lodge it's the best they're
comforting there's hot chocolate hot
girls hot girls hot fire just splash
some water on your face be like oh i had
a gnarly session on the hill today
went fast and totally
beef curtained it
let's get it scotch drink and cognac in
the tub
exactly
you're a class actor and uh
so yeah